welcome to the dfj entrepreneurial
thought leader seminar series presented
by stvp basis and the Stanford center
for professional development
you know this series is generously
supported as you've heard over and over
by our good friends at dfj J professor
jerison it you can view us online
anytime with this one and any of the
others at a corner dot stanford.edu you
can also stay connected with us by
following an e corner on twitter that's
at a corner and I mean use the hashtag
Stanford ETL I mean Baum that hashtag
right now you can do that that's totally
up to fine with me so I am Tom Byers and
I have the distinct pleasure of having a
conversation with a with I'm proud to
say a friend of mine
Laurene Powell Jobs welcome her please
our paths have crossed and and she was
kind enough to accept my invitation
last fall to do this so here we are yes
I know at the time March seemed very far
away so is easy to say yes well what's
really interesting is I went up on the
web and I started looking around saying
well you know I'll see what her style is
and stuff like that because we've made
this decision to do a conversation
rather in the Town Hall format which
many of you custom to here and I found
you did most of the interviews you do
mostly interviewing not yet so I decided
you'd interview me today okay
so I was born in Atlanta or you could be
disappointed if this really happens
no Eli's not he's smiling with a were
the hit folks he would really like it
but I got a feeling like 99% yeah so
we'll just go back to what we were
anticipated I'm really happy our paths
cross today with 300 of our friends and
the other agreement we had was it would
be a conversation it and it would be
informal but we are here to inspire
inform and to entertain a little bit
because for the students in the room we
realize it's the ninth week this project
which people are in finals damn close
yeah so you remember that I'm happy to
try to be entertaining
so you rep so let's go back in your life
what you where did you go to undergrad I
went to the University of Pennsylvania
what did you what did you study
I had a dual major dual degree between
the undergraduate Wharton School and the
Arts and Sciences so I yeah I remember
see this BS and BS yeah what good tommix
oh so the way that that works everybody
gets a BSC but then you have a
concentration and my mind was in finance
mm-hmm and then in Arts and Sciences
studied political science and I also
took enough French to have the second
major so well let's get a shout-out to
our advertising my college tuition
dollars so I studied a lot well so let
me check in with who's here because we
we're a little unusual than coming to
speak say it the business schools view
from the top so how many of you are
engineering majors okay how many are you
in the business and law schools always
have a few welcome welcome how about
arts and humanities and Social Sciences
alright welcome welcome
to get sorts of good mix how many
undergraduates I love it and then at the
graduate level yes or split and then we
have we have others that we were welcome
how many people are interested in
entrepreneurship and innovation how
about entrepreneurship innovation for
some big hairy problems the world of
facing yeah so this is what this is
going to be about so I want to get to
that though by just I do want a little
bit of your journey so you go to Penn
and something happened between there and
here so you went you went to the
business school here MBA what did you
get an MBA because this comes up a lot
in our office hours you know I you know
what I after undergraduate I worked at
Goldman Sachs and sales and trading and
after almost four years I took my last
bonus and paid off my undergraduate
student debt and moved to Italy and read
a lot of books that I didn't have a
chance to read in those in those four
years and I thought I really wanted I
wanted a little bit more schooling but I
really wanted to understand what it was
like to be an entrepreneur and so I
applied to Stanford Stanford was the
only graduate school I applied to so one
of your classmates are here she runs
she's our counterpart over at the
Business School I don't know of Li is
here but that was kind of cool she was
your classmate said yeah there you are
hi she is the director of the Center for
entrepreneurial studies there so which
we're really close to so it's it's it's
this a nice own connect
and I mean lo and behold I forgot to
mention she's a member of the board of
trustees at this university which is
pretty cool we and I'm lucky to say that
my brother is so you guys are on that on
that boarding a way I wouldn't just
check in about what does the Board of
Trustees do you work really hard but
what is it what is the role here well
it's it's a true governance board so we
have governance oversight over the
University and the Medical Center both
so it's an enormous enterprise and truly
it requires a lot of work because it's a
very complex enterprise you to wrap your
head around so I think basically I'm
your boss Elena's boss to them and Tina
oh boy I'm gonna work late tonight to
5:30 of that decide somewhat that noted
and okay so let's speaking of
entrepreneur you started something let's
get at it
called college track about 20 years ago
I get that right you and Carlos Carlos
and I Carlos and I first volunteered at
common high school almost 20 years ago
and then college track was formed about
17 years ago okay yes so we I want to
run a clip I don't know if this is the
right way Jim but could or you want to
set up the clip yeah at the time though
20 years ago I actually had started a
company out of business school I did
indeed start a company in 91 after I
graduated and I ran that until 96 ish
but in 95 Carlos and I went to karma in
high school for what we thought was
going to be a one day visit to a school
and it ended up changing both of our
lives so let's see how I have friends
you say I'm gonna drop out during high
school why would you want to drop out
when you can make your life so much
better my parents actually didn't go to
college they dropped out of elementary
school to go help support the family so
they did they know nothing about higher
education yeah I went to college track I
started in my freshman year so I think
that was like 98 my name is Marlene
Castro um I am a college track alumni
from the East Palo Alto site and I am
now an Oakland teacher fighting for my
students it's hope there's always hope
especially for someone that is trying to
make something of themselves
my little brother wants to go to
Stanford if for those things to happen
you know they need to have that support
they need to have people that believe
you know we surrounded by this you know
this whole college track atmosphere in
order for them to get there the main
thing is that I feel like it's gonna
happen once again that 14-year old
college try I set an example for him so
he wants to learn in his important my
name is Cheng Wei Liang and I am a
second-year UC Berkeley I utilize
college track a whole lot still because
the resources are for me to use from
from middle school all the way till I
graduated college college was not even
something I actually had in mind before
I moved to no was I didn't even think I
was cut out of college I was the the
guinea pig for our family and sense of
like how to get through high school and
how to apply to college so that my
younger brother and now my younger
cousins can also go through it with my
support somewhere deep inside you is
somebody that wants to succeed is
somebody that wants to become more than
what they are right now so this program
isn't just here to help the smarter kids
I just think it's smarter it's to help
the kids that are falling behind so they
can get better I want to go around
telling people we can do anything that
we set our minds to even if it's in the
little crowd and anyway speaking to one
person that one person can pass on to
other people I want the next generation
to see us as the role model because
Noah's that I had going up pushing me
forward were strong role models so if
I'm a strong role model that means the
next generation gets a strong role model
and there comes an even stronger
generation even stronger generations
will become
generation they changes the world with
everything that we do when I first
started college track my GPA was 2.0 but
Gianna and and a lot of college track
people they gave me the support they
gave me the resources that I need to
succeed and my grace improved like by a
lot
so my last GPA in high school was a 4.8
and without that I'd be struggling so so
much right now you just you don't even
know how much these people have helped
me Coty's track is like my family
they're my blood I bleed Connor strike I
think Kirk has changed my life I think
it has made me get out there and talk to
people and tell them yes I'm Chicano and
yes I don't come from one of the best
communities or whatever you want to say
but that doesn't mean I'm not gonna call
college that doesn't mean I'm not gonna
get into Harvard
Esme I'm not gonna become a lawyer maybe
you're president that's what it means
College check gives us ideas to do those
things I want to make a difference and
impact my community by becoming a lawyer
and just showing that we're here and
that we have our own perspectives and
that we can bring a lot to this country
and make a difference I literally feel
like college track is was at that time
and still continues to be a lifeline for
how I am able to just continue to find
success and be able to define that for
people as still in my community I'm not
just some other kid trying to go to
college
I want to be somebody I want I want
I want to be somebody that people look
at who's like I want to be like him I
realize that I can be that person
without college track I just would not
be here today
does anybody have any goosebumps I want
to be somebody I know I want to be
somebody who is that fellow is that he's
that he's that Dillard University right
now so while we could go in a few
directions here so what does this have
to do with entrepreneurship innovation
connect those dots
well it's social entrepreneurship and
and it's innovating around a system
that's rather intractable and finding
those points where where you can come in
with creativity and thought leadership
and change things up in this case change
things up for people's lives and be be
that inflection point that that a rather
calcified system doesn't allow for
typically so I had I started in
for-profit entrepreneurship but when
Carlos and I went and spoke to that
classroom at Carlmont high school we met
we met students like the students who
are in that video and in fact exactly
one of them indeed who became in our
first class of college tracked what we
found was though we saw we found such
such a failed system that it needed kind
of an exogenous shock it needed the the
type of entrepreneurship and
problem-solving that that I was I was
doing in the for-profit space that I
thought what a higher and better use of
my life to do it in the social sector
but you brought a an intensity and a
flair to it that we typically see it in
tech you know but then it to bring in
just the whole style about just the
style of that I mean there's a bit of
theater than that because I teared up
the other day like I was at a watching
that that just like I was watching a you
know
the nominee for the Academy Awards so
with that well well change requires
movements and movement requires
communications and marketing and so
that's what that's what you're seeing it
it happens to also be the truth and it
happens to be deeply powerful because
it's people's authentic words but it's
nevertheless a type of marketing the
other thing struck me as is the engineer
in me you know it's data I mean if you
go to college track org or whatever if
you go to the homepage immediate you see
that and that grabs your heart but then
you know I'm satisfied as the engineer
below as you set metrics I mean you say
cuz you set measurable goals and some
showed up you actually have over 2,000
already I think right well on the way
yes this year this year we're serving
2,000 students but we have over 200
college graduates who have gone through
the entire program we started off with a
high school program that was all about
sincere college readiness but what we
discovered is when students are first in
their families to go to college they
actually need support all the way
through to complete college so then we
extended the program to ten years so we
gave students six years to complete
college okay well I just like the
attention to well well there's there's
there's no way to know if you're
actually reaching your goals and
effecting the change if you don't
collect data so you have to be
data-driven the same principles apply in
the nonprofit space as they do in the
for-profit space that's such that's
that's a really important comment can
you expand on that a little bit because
that we get asked this a lot the name of
our Center is the Stanford Technology
Ventures program and they say well that
means you don't do social
entrepreneurship and so I helped us on
this well I think I think that
philanthropy and nonprofit space used to
be used to be sort of characterized as a
softer space but but actually that's not
the case at all with the advent of
venture philanthropy and impactful and
people are people who really look
to the space to effect change and people
go I think everyone in their lives if
they have an ocean and a philosophy of
what they want to do with their time on
the planet they want to have impact and
affect change and the only way you can
do that is through metrics and goals and
then strategies and tactics it's the
exact same way that you accomplish
anything
in either space well today we're going
to focus on education and immigration
which would sort of build of that but
you know there's another way that we get
to hang out occasion on occasion is
Conservation International I just wanted
to move digress for a minute that is a
large NGO in the environmental space and
they're very much science driven
data-driven yeah and that's what
attracted me to I don't know why you're
on their board as well and I don't know
why you chose that of all the things you
could do but it certainly was the
science that that attracted afternoon
and I agree with you I mean their
science is impeccable but their
leadership is equally impeccable and I
think that Peter Seligman's one of the
great entrepreneurs in the world and he
happens I think to the good fortune of
all of us to be in the social sector in
trying to really move the needle in the
environmental area well but we're gonna
go after two of that we're gonna climb a
couple of other hills okay and we
started on that climb by noting our
college track and it's continues to be
you know schedule continues to scale as
somebody put it as we were getting prep
to this one of your team members said
that it was a bit of the DNA of what
turned into Emerson collective
your your your system your set of
processes here in this decade so can we
talk about that so what is Emerson
collectives involvement in education
well college track indeed informed and
continues to inform me and and my my
work practice because I get to work with
students day in day out and really hear
from them and be responsive
to them I think it would be a big
mistake to move away from from that
direct service that grassroots impact
and information that is that K through
12 for instance well so Emerson is is
mainly focused on high school though
what we see is obviously you can't focus
on one part of the system so we've
expanded our desire to change the entire
system looking at all inputs into both
the system and and what comprises the
ecosystem of the public education in
America so so what I mean by that is our
system is broken if any if any students
here who've gone through the public
education system know as the promise of
the great equalizer and the prepare of
our citizenry it is unfortunately
failing because students continue to
drop out there deep inequities in the
public education system they're deep
inequities in teaching and learning and
it's based on a notion of time because
it was started a hundred years ago
during the industrial age when time as a
unit of measurement was very efficient
and so people serve the same amount of
time in the system but their learning is
variable we think that should be flipped
we think the learning should be at the
high standard and the time on task
should be variable so that changes that
requires system change so how do you do
about that well well what are some
examples
well we're we have a portfolio of
organizations that we support in the
for-profit sector in EdTech in the
nonprofit sector and then we have our
own initiatives that we've taken on so
let's do EdTech because we we had a one
of the leaders of the new school
ventures that's a--fun which you're our
doctor I don't know
when you know I'm only on four board
okay
she spoke in this series resident and
talked too good a bit I think must have
been last spring if I got that right
mm-hmm
so she she took you through sort of the
burgeoning EdTech sex yeah it is hot
it's happened yeah it's starting to
break wide open it's actually really
really because I think it was that for
those who were here at or want to know
more because we got a lot of you know
engineering I think yeah I think what's
really exciting is that's become a
viable market you're seeing a lot of
for-profit entrepreneurs enter the space
you saw a lot of non-for-profit
entrepreneurs first enter the space like
Wendy Kopp 25 years ago starting Teach
for America and then the the 35,000
people that have gone through that have
many of them have stay most of them have
stayed in the ed sector and they started
new schools and they started new
companies and they run districts and so
they have a whole different change
mentality but but also what's breaking
wide open is the role of technology and
teaching and learning has become an
incredibly valuable tool and of course
actually education is big business over
a trillion dollars is spent in education
each year in the United States and so so
some of the monopolies that were held by
say the textbook industry are starting
to crack open I think also the the
consumers are becoming far more savvy
about learning you know through
technology and so having technology
enabled teaching and learning and
they're willing to pay for it so it's
it's an exciting time I think we're
going to see massive changes because of
that and it in its I'm thinking of a
piece I saw that was sent over that you
had five priorities that was one of them
and that obviously caught my eye yeah
but the way that Emerson collective
works not to get too too wonky in here
but we're rather agnostic about the way
that that our capital is deployed so we
work in this 2c3 space which is the
nonprofit space and
port and we're really attracted to
breakthrough entrepreneurs there we work
in the sea for space which is it issue
advocacy so so people who are doing
grassroots organizing and issue advocacy
in state and at the federal level we
support we support because schools and
actually education is political we spend
political dollars based on people who we
believe are trying to do the right thing
for kids and then we have for-profit
investing so so we were really fortunate
to actually have all sorts of Portman
and on the political side is that local
or national or both I mean do ya the
governance unit for schools is the
school board and so you have to you have
to look at the municipalities the
district level the state level and
federal level okay so where are you
feeling like you're making progress and
where are you frustrated because I know
you're gonna put push boundaries so you
know just ten like we're sitting here
just they're not listening well I feel
like this is my life's work
so if I were frustrated now that would
be really sad for me so I'm extremely
hopeful but but hope plus work is what
affects change and so we have deeply
intellectual work and technical work and
organizational work in addition to hope
in in the resiliency of humankind and
you can see when we get to work with
students and we visit schools all the
time we visit failing schools and we
visit extraordinary schools both and so
whenever I travel I want to visit one of
each or if I don't have time for two I
want to see the schools that are
actually failing the students so that it
it recommit Smee
to do this work on behalf of as many
kids as I can help well again and
getting prep for this I had an epiphany
it looks I think you're in a really
rather unique position because you you
understand all those angles or quadrants
I mean in other words you understand
that nonprofit world the policy world
you understand the startup in technology
world I mean
you really you get all of it in your gut
and you can get in there mm-hmm
because otherwise you want talk about
rhetoric we're going to get to rhetoric
in a moment and partisanship with the
immigration stuff but yeah education
there's a good bit of that too right you
got well are you ready unions are not
like the last election here in
California for its State Superintendent
of Schools I mean I got really yes
nasty yeah it was funny like that's what
my frustration came from we were talking
about education and but these these ads
were or just ya know um well for some
people the stakes are very high and when
you're part of the status quo and you're
protecting your power base you're gonna
fight for it and so that's
understandable it's also understandable
that if people are not satisfied with
with what's happening in our country and
with our output they should fight for
change too and so on the other hand what
often gets lost in the mix is the voice
of students and so so at Emerson we we
always like bringing it back to the
voice of students really to ask them you
know is this working for you and parents
is this working for you and if the
answer is no then then actually the zero
sum and and politicking that goes on and
and the discussions that are only about
what's good for adults is not acceptable
so that's completely compatible with
what we teach in our courses regarding
entrepreneurship in terms of if we're
talking about for-profit you know
customer development code get out of the
building as they say you know and go
with your customers yeah and the
d.school they talking about needs
finding I mean it is it is completely
compatible what we're trying to do
usually using the the cases being you
know a tech a piece of technology but
it's it applies yeah yes it's one on one
it does all right well let's go to the
the rhetoric yes and we'll have time for
questions yeah so we can come back okay
we back around education yeah
that I know it's it's such a layered and
complex issue and deeply fascinating I
think and so it requires layered and
complex
Lucian's education yeah yeah let's talk
about immigration sure is that's you
know the it's topical it's relevant it's
central to our country and warlike
topical today's news I mean yeah in the
United States because we have a global
audience the United States that the
funding of the Department of Homeland
Security was held up over the last week
over this particular item about the
president why so much oh well I mean
look if you look at immigration
historically as an issue I don't think
there's ever been a time when a group
has been let in that they don't want to
close the door behind them and that's
just it's just how our country has
evolved and there's always been a time
where a group of individuals has been
scapegoated and vilified and then
finally assimilated and then they become
Americans on the other hand there's
never been a time when when our economic
engine hasn't been fueled by new
immigrants to our country is our
replenishing is our refueling it's
essential for the continuation and the
continued economic growth for our
country we know this however people when
people are suffering they like
scapegoating others and and there are
some people who are who are serving in
the United States Congress who are
completely rigid and there are a few who
have a big megaphone who are hate
mongering and it's to the detriment of
all of us now we have had we've had
across our country a desire for
immigration reform for years and and it
the both parties in across the United
States and another tool that we use is
we do a lot of national and local
polling and so in this case we did a lot
of polling in districts in communities
in states nationally so that
we were informed again we gathered data
we listened to people we did focus
groups I attended focus groups in
Arizona and Texas and Ohio and Virginia
and no matter what the majority of the
people and most of them were Republican
audiences the majority of them wanted
common-sense immigration reform in fact
we have a super majority of Americans
who want this it's not happening right
now we do not have a representative
democracy around this issue and that
that needs to change and so and so we
ask ourselves well given given this set
of information how do we actually affect
change how do we try to raise the
consciousness raise the awareness
bring this to the fore so that
constituents actually speak out to their
representatives and say in this case
because federal policy is the end goal
there's not a lot of mitigation between
between what we can do as citizens and
what the federal policy can do for them
so so we can start demanding that they
that their votes reflect our wishes
sure so perhaps I should just back up
the reason Emerson collective yes so
because college track does inform so
much of our work in 2001 when when our
first group of students were applying to
college we found that there was a
significant percentage of students who
were undocumented they found out at the
same time we found out because they
didn't have a Social Security number and
they couldn't apply to college and then
then we they couldn't they couldn't fill
out the FAFSA forms and they couldn't
they didn't qualify for state and
federal loans or any kind of funding or
grant for their education and so we had
made it both an explicit and implicit
promise to our students that if they
followed all these steps you know we put
together very
bust and demanding program that that we
would help them get through college so
we had to fulfill our promise but I
started to understand the purgatory that
undocumented because he started yeah and
then in 2006 then President Bush was
very committed to immigration reform and
he unfortunately didn't bring that to
pass we thought that was going to pass
and then we had an opportunity when we
had both houses of Congress and the
presidency all Democrats who said they
wanted immigration reform they didn't
bring it up to passage so they didn't
complete it and it just it just became
the most shocking intractable
intractable problem we had students that
are continuing now I mean this is an
issue that people have started to be
aware of for over a decade and nothing
has changed in meanwhile we now know we
all know we have 11 million people who
are living in this purgatory we I mean
the conservative estimates are that the
the boost to our economy would be six
hundred billion dollars over over an
eight-year period and probably quite a
bit higher every year we have 650,000
students who graduate from high school
in the u.s. who are undocumented and all
and their only option up until the
executive action was to work in the cash
industry can we play the video now yes
so yes so the video that he's that
doctor virus is talking about is are you
doctor I have a PhD but I'm not that
kind of let's put a face on this that's
so what we decided to do was we we
thought our contribution in this case
could be marketing and
awareness and so we produced a
documentary and we built out a website
and we kind of knitted together the
activist communities and then I'll tell
you what we ended up doing with the film
we hired Davis Guggenheim who's a great
documentary filmmaker and he made a 30
minute film for us that was screaming
spoken very very widely yeah y'all cool
so can we play yeah it's bigger than a
website deeper than a documentary
more powerful than a petition it's a
story about people instead of calling
them illegals let's call them occupiers
or trespassers or invaders or squatters
same day that I graduated I checked my
mouth and I had got a full scholarship
I get a call from the admissions office
we're really sorry but you can't get
your scholarships anymore I have a
degree you have all this what am i doing
you can dream all you want but you're
still here the DREAM Act is legislation
that says he came to the US as a child
we will give you a chance to be legal in
America growing up always say I want to
be in the military he's the kind of guy
that our military needs who always
imagine what it would feel like to be
told you know ready ladies
my summa laude medal that could be
deported in the spring am I gonna be
able to finish the semester you know
it's real
to me
I can't get a driver's license I can't
have a state ID I qualified for
everything
I just can't fill in that space for your
social for you I want to graduate I want
to go to college I want to be a doctor
We the People said I believe the phrase
was no way Jose either you're not gonna
live in to ever anymore today that's a
life injustice better to fight
this really is the future of our country
I'm gonna be arraigned
this is more than a movie it's a
movement
upload your photographs but a human face
to the petitioner
the time is right
the choice is real the dream is now
where was that set the timeline that was
2013 we made that that 2013 and that's a
full movie it's 30 minutes 30 minutes
yes it's a it is a full movie we
screened it in the US Capitol in fact
that was our premiere screening and that
and we had all the students that are
profiled in the film and their families
there and a number of of Congress people
came and then we screened it for the
some of members of the Republican caucus
the Democratic caucus in the House of
Representatives and then we've screened
it on MSNBC it's on Netflix iTunes over
a hundred we put together at college
campus screening movement so we screened
on over a hundred college campuses as
well and a lot of the students who are
profiled in the film helped to manage
all of the activism and the screenings
and they smoke it most of them we also
have some photos that was from another
yes so yeah part of what you're showing
is different ways you know I think it
kind of stretches the the definition of
an entrepreneur I feel like an
entrepreneur is nimble and creative and
still very goal-oriented
and tenacious yeah and I think you know
you tried to you tried to do more than
you think is possible with with less
than do you think this is entrepreneur
absolutely I think it's directly
connected to it because there's a lot of
headwind there's a lot of forces and
this this is yeah you know swimmy
whatever metaphor this is swimming
against the tide because it is it is a
grind so something else that we did as
we were pushing for this to happen is we
wanted to we want to have community
engagement be
because all change is sustained by
communities and so we partnered with the
photographer jr. and we went we fitted
out kind of retro fitted these FedEx
buses or vans and made them into mobile
photo booths and people would show up at
the cities we went to 19 cities around
the u.s. and have their their portraits
taken and their their giant their
life-size portraits that get printed out
and in each city where where we went we
stayed for several days and we used a
lot of social media and we would paste
up iconic structures and buildings and
so there are a couple of see a couple
can you do a Chan that this is quite
remarkable oh that's that sound
yep yep so that's Selma that's the Selma
bridge mm-hmm oh and those are all those
are portraits of yeah individuals and
they're on the bridge holding it Wow and
then the next one Chad let's have it
this is yep don't look at that's a
college campus Plaza
I think it's UNC I just crossed the pond
yeah it was gigantic that pasting well
and I think there's one more that is so
so that's kind of what's a little hard
to see here I don't know if you all can
see it there but that at the end of our
campaign this is in front of the Capitol
on the Capitol lawn and we had we had
gigantic portraits of four individuals
one is a dreamer one is an entrepreneur
he might have I think he spoke in your
class or maybe his brother Patrick
Collison yeah yeah that's John they're
all immigrants and then to others I
can't tell where they're Stacey Katella
mm-hmm
and their different faces different
profiles of immigrants in the United
States and so you could see this right
outside of Speaker Boehner Sophos which
was right there
we did get in a little bit of trouble
for killing the grass so we had to
replant it but and then then we wrote up
this manifesto and this is an ad that we
took out in The Wall Street Journal and
The Washington Post so we use all
different types of media so what's next
oh what's one more yeah let's talk about
that yeah you want to do that or yeah
well then talk about what's next this is
this a truly unlike this story yeah so
this is a this is a picture of Jose who
was profiled in the dream is now movie I
think you saw him briefly he was showing
his diploma from ASU he's a mechanical
engineer and he was he was doing
construction work but with the
president's executive action in 22 2012
no 2013 no 2012 executive action yeah no
parents no the parent is now well now
that was yeah the original is 2012 and
that was a two-year program he ended up
getting daca stands for deferred action
for childhood arrivals so for the
dreamers who we were advocating for many
of them qualified to live free from fear
of deportation under this but it was
only it was it's a temporary program and
his renewal of daca and what's called
dhaba which is deferred action for for
parents arrivals is what the Republican
House of Representatives was trying to
hold up in the DHS funding but Jose
ended up getting daca status which means
he could get a work permit and he was
hired by Teach for America in Arizona
and this is him in his classroom this
year in September because when he first
got out with his mechanical engineering
degree he was not allowed to work in
that profession it was just go out be a
daily know you you're exactly right of
course you couldn't get a work permit
yeah so that's what he did was just
daily construction
a fine line between you know those of us
sitting in the room and that really fine
line know that it's it's all of our
story so do you want to take questions I
think we'd better because I've run out I
don't think anyone believes that okay
let's have some hands how about right
here what's kick it kale for you speak
up Thanks so really inspiring stories
with all these kids program we teach a
lot of younger kids and one of the
things we see that really makes a
difference particularly the kids with
special needs is that they're so often
told so often told what they can't do
and in my experience teaching it a
computer Clubhouse for kids with
farmworker kids similar kind of problems
they're all they don't expect the
colleges for them that's for other
people do you see how do you see that
playing out do you have any stories of
some of these kids changing how they
think about themselves yes we have a we
have many students with college track
students over 90% of college track
students are first in family to access
any higher education and so 96% are
first and family to go to a four-year
college and because you don't have that
tradition in your family or in your
community if you don't get it from your
school you're not the encouragement the
high expectations that role modeling
that you see yourself in you're not
going to get it and so we have to we
have to make this change student by
student classroom by classroom family by
family school by school and that's that
whole culture and mindset is is right at
the core of the change that needs to
happen let me see if I'm going to see
get a student far back right there yeah
that's you yes
so we've already established the work
that you're doing is entrepreneurial in
nature and as every speaker before you
has spoken that that's really hard work
it requires a lot of sacrifices and in
part that's at least to some extreme
compensated by financial incentive the
fact that you might make him big and
have a lot of financial payoff but the
kind of work you're doing does not have
that at all as a nonprofit you're not
able to make that set of money so how do
you fit this entire thing into a picture
how can we how can we change so that
more people actually can make that
decision of working really hard towards
problems that may not pay off in terms
of money you know what social
entrepreneurs generally don't make a lot
of money it's true they just don't
there are intrinsic rewards that are off
the charts the extrinsic rewards are
limited I think you know you what I'm
seeing in this sector though is is a
very very healthy living but you're
never gonna get the kind of you know
breakthrough and and wild upside that
you see in the for-profit sector it's
just and so you have to reconcile
yourself to that and be willing to make
a fine living but maybe not maybe not
have the kind of wild financial success
that you can have in the for-profit
sector now there that's one that's one
that's actually reality right but then
what if we thought okay what if we
really wanted to incent the best and the
brightest to go into the social sector
to to effect the kind of change that is
required there how could we think about
this differently what if we had a
startup fund that social entrepreneurs
got shares in that say all the VCS in
Silicon Valley contributed to what if
some established companies put aside
some sort of bonuses for people who are
having have breakthrough change ideas or
who are equipping communities to be
agents of their own change I mean there
are a lot of different ways we as a
society can start
just changing up the financial rewards
so that it can become a much more
exciting from a from a financial point
of view exciting career path than it
currently is to me there's no work like
this there's no work that gives me the
level of reward that that one gets when
when you see like the students who you
saw in the college track video students
who finally understand they can do
anything they want with their lives
that's that's a tremendous payout but
financially I think we need to reorient
as a society a little bit so that
there's more of an alignment well said
right here this is more about your
career you as women have you ever faced
any limits or any barriers in society
when you enter the world of finances or
how do you achieve them how do you
jumped like from them well when I first
started out on the sales and trading
floor and fixed income at Goldman Sachs
but there were 10 10 % women on that
trading floor now I was lucky because I
grew up with three brothers so I was
used to just being surrounded by men and
boys and so it wasn't all that different
from my kitchen table when I grew up but
there were plenty I mean it was not for
the faint of heart it was not for the
thin-skinned to be on a trading floor
there were plenty of times when there
were terrible things said to me about
other you know all sorts of things you
know I've been out of that industry for
a long long time I think the world has
changed a lot I think there's a lot more
acknowledgement and sensitivity and
probably there's still a lot of machismo
on a trading floor I haven't been on one
lately but what I think you know I if
there are other compensations if you go
into if whatever
career path you take you can actually
not be surprised you can actually kind
of try things out you can you can shadow
people you can get a sense of of the
culture and different sectors and
industries and you have to see where you
feel most comfortable how about right
here immigrants I love what you're doing
we all know that his broker you
mentioned it and I know that Kaka D Mia
hasn't changed in a while and it
probably won't so what is something that
we can do as heads or contra premiers
we'd either support full support of
academia that can actually move the
needle and really support students in
higher ed is you're asking about higher
ed because I know in K through 12 right
now because the teachers are younger
they're starting to adopt technology a
lot easier than in higher education so
that yeah that's an interesting that's
an interesting point of view I and at
Emerson we just met with Carl Wyman who
many of you may know he's a joint
professor at the ed school and in the
physics department and he's here at
Stanford and he is a treasuries a Nobel
Prize winning physicist but he's so
deeply committed to changing up how big
lectures are taught in science and how
science is taught in higher ed what's
going on here and he's working with the
faculty and so you should go meet with
him right away he's really interesting I
think also the your Dean the Dean of
engineering is incredibly creative and
innovative and is really looking for
ways to change up how education happens
this is where you ask me about epicenter
though also I believe you have a program
called episode yeah yes thank gosh thank
you so come see me or anybody across the
hall where we're working
changing faculty and students in
colleges so that everybody gets to learn
about entrepreneurship and innovation
and we're doing that in a systemic way
Thanks ok right here how did you decided
to focus your project in this specific
part of the population I mean why did
you decided to work in improving the
dedication and with this specific
characteristics instead of book singing
any other thing
well it
the genesis of my awareness and
awakening' came just from visiting a
classroom in a local high school by
chance I went a friend of mine and I
were asked to go and speak to a high
school this was 20 years ago to a class
and these were classes students from
East Palo Alto which is right next door
to us and they were seniors in high
school who had been told that they were
that they were in a college prep course
and the teacher had asked us to speak to
them about college in general and then
the teacher had explained to us that at
this high school come on high school at
the time there were 1,700 students and
there was one college counselor and so
she said unfortunately no one in my
class has gotten to see a college
counselor yet so we'd like you to come
and speak about college and so we said
we'd be delighted and we came in and
what we found very quickly was that of
the 35 students in the class three as
seniors three had taken the required
courses to even apply to a four-year
school so 32 couldn't even apply and
when I found that out I decided that
this was such an abomination and such an
injustice and it was happening right in
my back yard that there was I could do
nothing but devote my life to trying to
understand why this happened and what
can do to change it for the project was
because of that it really was it really
was I guess you know sometimes in life
you can really pinpoint the moment when
things change for you that's a great
question we like asking that if people
Tina taught me this question three words
what motivates you and I meant to ask
you that question at both segments of
our discussion the one about education
and one about immigration so I'm going
to take the last question though it's
not that one thank you for helping me
remember that this is dial back time
you're a pen
you're 20 years old what would you tell
yourself oh right now yeah you're out
here you're back in pen you're sitting
in some lecture I would say I would tell
myself to have faith I think I was I you
know I I was in middle class kid I was I
went to a high school that did not
adequately prepare me for college I
worked really really hard academically
and I also had a work-study job and I
had a job outside of work-study and and
I and I was not relaxed I had a lot of
student debt I had I was financially
independent and I had a lot of pressure
and I think I didn't allow myself to
think expansively about my life because
there were exigencies that needed to be
attended to but I I always had sort of
big dreams you know I I was always so
intrigued and enchanted by social
movements but I didn't think that I can
do that because you know back to the
first students question I actually you
know financially I really needed to
figure things out and I think I would
tell myself to relax and the time would
come because if I stayed true to myself
the way that life evolves you end up
getting to do what you think is your
highest and best use did you have a good
time you mean now yeah yeah
all right did you have a good time thank
you so much
you